yo what is up everybody just procedure
man Luigi here inside of the witcher 3
with a new way kind of a glitch of how
to get a infinite amount of money inside
of this game now this is going to be
achieved by doing a duping glitch on
monsters nest so to do this you're going
to just go to any monsters nests in the
game which is just you can find them
anywhere there are a lot of contracts
for him you're gonna kill the monsters
near just blow up the nest and then
you're gonna loot everything inside of
the nest except for one item make sure
you don't loot every item if you do it's
not going to work so you're gonna loot
every item except for one you can see
the autism's they have really good loot
such as like a gold ring which is really
inexpensive and it's worth a lot of
money so you're going to get a lot of
gold rings from this so you're gonna
want to loot everything and then you're
just going to turn away and turn back at
it the trick is to get the monster nest
out of your screens rendering view and
then it will reset the loot as you can
see the loop just keeps resetting every
single time and I'm leaving the skulls
inside because I don't really want those
goals the mic up there basically going
to be the most worthless thing in mind
and you see there's a lesser glyph and
the Rings and both of those you get like
10 of those it's 2,000 bucks for both of
them that's 4,000 bucks just with doing
this ten times and this takes as you can
see this takes like three seconds to do
so that's basically the entire strategy
of how to do this this is a very good
way to get a lot of money fast because
you get a lot of expensive material that
is very cheap to that a very low on
weight so you can hold a lot of is you
can make a lot of money from doing this
a good place to sell this would be a the
blacksmith in novigrad I know usually
has a ton of money and the people in big
cities such as no regret will have a lot
of money do this with so as you can see
i'm just going to show like these things
are with a ton of money so guys i hope
you have enjoyed it is a video is a
quick little thing most of my with your
videos have been quick little tips if
you did enjoy this check out my channel
i'm going to be posting more with your
content and I do have some Witcher 3
content already up so you guys hope you
enjoyed this video if you if you end up
like in this video or have you seen some
of my other videos like this one too you
think my channel is pretty great I would
really appreciate any subscriptions
because that definitely helps my channel
grow and chose me that I'm doing
something right so you guys hope you
enjoyed and I'll see y'all ACB watching
in my other videos peas up